[Música]
ah
y
la historia que le vengo a contar hoy
comienza aquí en nuestra querida hermosa
facultad de ciencias veterinarias de la
universidad nacional de rosario nuestra
querida facultad de casilda allí en 1983
comienzo porque para ser médico
veterinario para que para asistir a los
animales en sus cuestiones de salud
los veía extremadamente desprotegidos y
además en algún momento de la
adolescencia me crucé con una frase de
gandhi que dice que las sociedades se
juzgan por cómo tratan a sus animales y
con ese romanticismo inicie la carrera
conocí gente increíble
fue una experiencia de vida muy grande
de mucho crecimiento
donde obtuve conocimientos y realmente
no eran tantos como los que yo quería o
necesitaba en ese momento
pero bueno
en 1988 me recibo
con poco menos de pero blanco y menos
kilos
y ya al poquito tiempo abro mi primer
veterinaria
qué es lo que sabíamos claramente
que los perros no comen huesos y abrir
mi veterinaria pensando en hacer ese
apostolado los perros no comen huesos le
contaba a la gente a los clientes nuevos
y me miraban con una lástima
imaginen 40 años atrás explicándole a la
gente
que los perros no comían huesos pero
pero se ve que algunos algunos convencí
porque a los meses a los pocos meses de
estar instalados se cruza el carnicero
no con un tono tan amigable me dice
doctorcito
yo no sé de dónde estudiaste
pero los perros comieron comen y van a
comer huesos y con tres palmaditas
firmes sentencia no me arruines el
negocio
bueno ahí comprendió un par de cosas la
primera que cambiar paradigmas
culturales es muy difícil y cuando hay
intereses económicos peor mucho peor
y la otra es que no todos los comienzos
son fáciles y el mío no podría ser la
excepción
de la facultad nunca me pude ir es un
gran amor
empecé de ayudante y hoy soy profesor
investigador
y en la parte clínica hago solamente
dermatología de perros y gatos
y en ese camino en tantos años pasaron
cosas una vez comienzo a encontrar unas
estructuras muy pequeñas
unas pelotitas adheridas a los glóbulos
rojos de los perros y luego ya el
microscopio con cierta asiduidad
es muchos perros consultó a los popes
y vuelve a experimentar esa cara de
lástima de los clientes que me dicen
dónde estudiaste los perros no tienen
esto
pero eso lo veía
bueno junto unas muestras las envió a
eeuu a un laboratorio de referencia
y a la vuelta de correo
es cuando ese momento que se abre el
cielo baja el rayo de luz cantan los
ángeles y me informan que las
estructuras que yo había encontrado eran
mycoplasma emoc anís mycoplasma
te mato park boom
y se transformó en el primer informe en
argentina de estas bacterias en perros
otra vez cambiando paradigmas y con
cierta resistencia pero con este
hallazgo nos pone una situación
extremadamente incómoda porque estas
bacterias más allá del nombre con
algunos parásitos que son transmitidos
por pulgas y garrapatas enfermando a los
perros a los gatos y también a las
personas
es una realidad que ya está
es un grupo de enfermedades que la
organización mundial de la salud ya no
las clasifica como emergentes sino las
clasifica como negligencia das
esta enfermedad el grupo vulnerable es
el de mayor pobreza donde no tienen
recursos para cubrir las necesidades
básicas donde viven los nadie de
galliano
con perros que son menos que los nadie
de galliano y en esta realidad
latinoamericana
también tenemos los perros y los oscar
los gatos de la calle por tanto lo que
tiene que hacerse en salud pública en
sanidad pública tiene hacerse ayer en el
mientras tanto nosotros los que podemos
pagar obtener una tenencia responsable
de nuestras mascotas es indispensable
colocarles árticas y los garrapaticidas
a nuestras mascotas todo el año no
cuando vemos una pulga o vemos la
garrapata porque ahí ya es tarde
es como el concepto de las caries uno se
lava los dientes para no tenerlas cuando
las vemos ya estar bien eso por un lado
en la actividad de clínico dermatólogo
también el proceso fue lento de lerdo
porque no hay escuelas no había escuelas
de dermatología en argentina
entonces comencé mi camino tomando
algunas herramientas por supuesto en
buenos aires'
aplicando las
de cuenta que no alcanza
generó ciertos medicamentos que hoy
gracias a un laboratorio se
comercializan en toda latinoamérica
pero el tema no pasaba por ahí porque
ese trabajo en solitario e impedía o no
visualizaba como docente cómo se podía
hacer para facilitar el aprendizaje de
esta rama de la veterinaria de hacerlo
de manera más accesible o más masiva
para los colegas entonces me reúno con
colegas de argentina y en el 2010
fundamos la sociedad argentina de
dermatología veterinaria
hicimos el primer congreso aquí en
rosario con el apoyo por supuesto de
nuestra querida facultad y del colegio
de veterinarios y la perlita del
congreso fue que vino un colega de nivel
superintencia nal el doctor tierra
colibrí francés pero hacía 30 años que
está trabajando en estados unidos y
luego de sus conferencias al momento de
la cena
nos dice muy bien lo de ustedes pero
siempre hay un pero es lo que juega en
el mundo hoy son las sociedades
continentales y faltaba la sociedad
latinoamericana de dermatología y otra
vez ver qué se hace cómo se resuelve
resistencia al cambio pero había que
cambiar ese
ajustar una ese paradigma mundial
por tanto por supuesto parte de la
comisión directiva estuvo en contra y
otra parte seguimos trabajando por el
bien común y al año siguiente fundamos
la sociedad latinoamericana que también
genera congresos para la difusión de
estos temas
aparece en esa instancia que estamos en
la gloria de la nada a peso
[Música]
calificamos como dermatólogos porque no
existe una academia como medicina humana
consultamos este doctor o libre y nos
devuelve
un cuestionario con un montón de ítems a
cumplir como por ejemplo asistencias
congresos conferencias dadas artículos
científicos escritos capítulos escritos
en fin era es eterno
yo la buena noticia la que tenía casi
todo completo la mala noticia es que me
faltaba una pasantía con uno de estos
referentes por uno o dos meses en eeuu
ya lo había dado por perdido y recibo un
email de este doctor o libre y que me
consulta gustavo qué vas a hacer con tu
pasantía te respondo que me interesa
muchísimo pero que el país no estaba en
un buen estado como siempre sabemos
y que me como no me a personal no estaba
en el mejor momento así que preferí
declinar esta posibilidad
en tiempo real me contesta
y me ofrece
mire puede parar en mi casa en mi casa
tengo una heladera con comida
yo voy y vengo todos los días a la
facultad así que lo puedo llevar y traer
lo único que no lo puedo evitar son los
20 dólares de la matrícula que cobra la
universidad estatal de carolina del
norte
con todo ese ofrecimiento lo primero que
se me produce es pensar qué pretende
usted de mí
vamos con la ciencia pero hasta ahí
y bueno
consulte con mi señora con mis hijos
hicimos la reunión
hicimos un avión hablamos en familia y
fue una sola voz andar
y bueno al poquito tiempo tuve el
privilegio de ser nombrado uno de los 17
dermatólogos latinoamericanos avalados y
con reconocimiento a nivel internacional
y ahí surge la frase esta de no te des
por vencido a un vencido
porque siempre cuando uno está en un
camino con una lucha con un trabajo en
equipo para abrir brechas siempre
aparece una solución
quedaba pendiente todo esto es
fantástico institucional genial pero
quedaba pendiente que hacía en mi casa
en la facultad
querida cada de casilda bueno hablamos
con las autoridades
se armó el servicio de dermatología que
asiste a los pacientes que llegan y los
que nos derivan de la región
al poco tiempo fundamos la asignatura
optativa de dermatología para asistencia
a los alumnos de la facultad
y largamos ya ahora la carrera de
posgrado de especialización en
dermatología de perros y gatos esto
desde aquel 1988 a esta parte pone a la
facultad de ciencias veterinarias de la
universidad nacional de rosario como
faro en la dermatología latinoamericana
también pero y para qué bueno para que
hoy los perros los gatos son parte de la
familia hoy yo les pregunto a ustedes
quién tiene mascotas levanten la mano
para todos
de todos ustedes quienes duermen con sus
mascotas
hoy estamos en un concepto de perry jo
gatillo
son parte ahmed y de los expertos
generan la pérdida de una mascota
comparable con la pérdida de un familiar
del duelo por un familiar y nuestro
compromiso es muy profesional es estar
al nivel para dar soluciones
las palabras serendipia que se la
definieron y son los hallazgos que uno
hace en el camino mi camino de búsqueda
era la construcción para la educación
para la difusión pero en el medio
descubrí cosas y conocimientos que no
buscaba
como por ejemplo
es importante y es fundamental conocer
las enfermedades
para curar a los pacientes pero también
es vital hoy escuchar
es importante conocer los medicamentos
pero también hay que contener
es fundamental ser puntual con los
horarios en las consultas por una
conducta ética y de respeto pero también
hay que acompañar
tenemos que cobrar un arancel digno
porque es nuestro sustento pero también
nuestro trabajo tiene gran parte de
solidario
y más importante aún no es suficiente
ser amable y cordial con nuestros
clientes y con nuestros pacientes es
fundamental ser empático tanto el dueño
como el perro es esa dupla que se da en
medicina veterinaria
dueño impact ota es una dupla que está
sufriendo el perro o el gato por por la
enfermedad y el dueño por ese
padecimiento de su mascota de su
pariente
por tanto hay muchas cosas para hacer
mucho camino por recorrer y siempre
tengo en mente la frase de louis pasteur
que dice que la medicina humana sana al
hombre y la medicina veterinaria sana a
la humanidad
[Música]
y